should have seen that a whale at fifteen
bragging to his followers on snapchat
this gang member from Coventry is now
serving a life sentence CCTV captured a
moment he filmed himself after stabbing
a man to death last year there are now
warnings of tensions fueled on social
media between gangs across the country
will lead to an increase in violent
crime once the lockdown is lifted a lot
of young people are boarding a fatigue
during covin 19 I think what this
criminologist says in Birmingham apps
like house party has already led to
rouse online being settled in the
streets there was a number of cases were
more specifically a recent case where
there was a number of shootings that
took place at particular residence where
people may have lived and that was as a
consequence of a argument that took
place on a social media application or
platform like house party tensions have
long existed between rival gangs in the
city a recent shooting at this chicken
shop was linked to an alleged dispute
between teenagers on social media now
snapchat has told us in a statement they
condemned at gang violence while house
party say the safety of users is
essential and they do not tolerate
illegal behavior some areas in London
are at the heart of gang turf wars which
has less communities living in fear 20
year-old Joseph Williams Torres was
killed in a case of mistaken identity
two years ago the three men who murdered
him were part of a gang who often used
social media to intimidate their rivals
it's everyday he will be hit for charge
you know like looking forward to see my
son to grow up to be with his friends
and to have a nice life like how I want
it and now he cannot have it they just
shot him five times and killed him they
tried to get out the car he pull them
back and then he just shot them in there
some police forces including a met are
now monitoring gang activity on
Instagram and YouTube we are very much
aware of the pressure cooker that has
developed when it comes to people
you know gang members or others who want
to create mayhem when this lockdown is
eased the social media platforms
whichever platform that is have been a
breeding ground for individuals to bait
each other during this during this
lockdown with tensions building out of
sight
the police node are quiet off lockdown
won't last for them though the challenge
is keeping up with gangs on social media
know Philips Sky News